I would love to play in the name of the
game is Christian Bale or Christian male
[Music]
I'll give your closes and you tell me
who said it either Christian Bale or a
Christian hey you got it mm-hmm
hey you shut up the door baby go away
Matthew Mac all right TIG the first
quote if you stay you will perish
follow me you will be free don't be
afraid God is with us it sounds like a
Christian male thank you
it was Christian Bale as Moses in Exodus
of the gods and kings and it didn't do
well internationally or domestically
next slope Harry Potter should use less
spells and sing more him Christian Bale
for a Christian male does a good
Christian male is all rap yes so stay
off the dead man for sake
alright let's go again let's not take a
mix let's go again I'm gonna kick you
death if you have shut up for one dad
who said it I it has to be Christian
Bale sad life Oh Jacob Lee wonderful ok
back lock I am going to come and burn
the house down ellipses but you you will
blow me first it does not sound very
Christian like so Christian Bale yeah
that is it correct that was a Christian
male by the name of Mel Gibson but you
got three out of four which means your
way I did yeah what a mile in shuffle
absolutely no